there was that one stunt that you didn't
want to do and I think it was jackass to
where you had to shove The Tao car up
your butt that that was the first one
that was the first movie and that was I
think the only time on record that we
have you saying no to a stunt correct
that was the first time that uh it was
acknowledged that i' backed out of
something and what why so why that stun
it was just like I just remember my dad
uh being particularly disappointed that
that was on the table and and I
attribute that to my dad being like old
school
homophobe he's like dudes don't mess
with but holes yeah for sure like he was
not worried about my safety